hey everyone John Willis here math and
Finance teacher at Mount Juliet
Christian Academy it is 27 degrees
outside very cold but we're about to
warm things up here we're at the local
Steak and Shake and we are about to do a
random act of kindness our finance class
has been coming here to Steak and Shake
for the past four years and we've got a
wonderful wonderful waitress that has
been serving us for four years and we
are hopefully about to bless her beyond
what she can what can she can imagine
four years ago this nice lady started
serving my students you guys will
remember Carver hibbett and fell upon me
and those guys and we came in I mean
think I knew your name we did but you
served us with a smile you loved every
minute of you call this your babies I
came two years ago you took my six
students we had John Carell Meredith
those guys came in you remember them two
years ago and then you brought you look
at that look how long ago we've grown
you know these guys we do our personal
finance class in our math class we've
taught a lot about getting through
college without debt we've talked a lot
about getting rid of those nasty credit
cards but the one thing we also talk is
about giving that's wrong and you've
been a servant to us for four years and
what we want to do is give her this card
first we made this wonderful card for
you oh that means more to me
you we learned a couple of weeks ago
then you have some bugs now look at this
you're gonna have to keep yourself under
control for this
Cody nalli Cody
drew this picture my hand look at that
we got all of our signatures on there we
wanted to say thank you for all your
years of service and we wanted to give
you this and we got one more this one we
hope you like we hope you laughed at
this one but if you will open this one
these kids for the last two and a half
months we've been saving a little bit of
money and we wanted to I know we didn't
have to do we wanted to bless you for
all the fun and blessings you've given
us stand up stand up yeah we can if you
need to sit down you sit down for a
minute here okay this is from all of us
to you you've been such a blessing to us
Martha thank you
blessings to me all year long as long as
you keep coming back we will